chère entreprise de distributeurs automatiques championne pour cinq
étages dans l'industrie qui aurait dû
me donner des M & Ms aux cacahuètes, malheureusement, ce n'est
pas le cas.
J'ai trouvé cela bouleversant car j'avais très
faim et ma femme était décédée 10
minutes plus tôt. Je ne dis pas que c'était de
ta faute.  pour être minutieux
Julia était une bonne personne elle a travaillé avec
des enfants ayant des besoins spéciaux elle ronflait quand
elle riait
maintenant mâchée je ne me sens même pas samedi
réparer le cœur humain c'est comme
préparer une automobile il faut
tout démonter il suffit d'examiner tout
puis tu  peut tout remettre en place,
ce qui m'a fait penser que si ce n'est pas
possible, vous effectuez généralement des appels de service
à 2h00 du matin
m.  J'essaie et à partir de là, ma femme vient de
mourir, ayez de la compassion,
que faisons-nous encore, nous démontons
ce mariage,
vous pensez qu'il est trop tard
pour tout reprendre
[Musique]